what was the story about yourself with
Fury and Jake Paul or he had trouble the
coaches had problems to come to America
when he was in a box right and I said
I'll be his coach because I just love
their family I mean I love what Tyson
Fury does you know if you just became a
world champion you grab the microphone
away from The Ring speaker and you start
singing a love song to your wife how
cool is that and together since they
were like 12 years old you know I mean
that's cool there's something very very
genuine about I can't stop watching this
guy but the brother Tommy Fury we talked
about Jake Paul earlier what was your
involvement I think that's what Pat was
asking you did you offer the corner yeah
what's the situation if you wanted to
come to train here in America that's
what was the talk you know I would
welcome him with open arms you know I
would love to train a guy like that but
is that a conversation that's actively
being taken place or it's more
unfortunately not yeah listen they have
they're doing really well so I mean look
at look at Tyson's body and the way that
he looks versus Tommy Tyson's way more
accomplished meanwhile you have this kid
who's chiseled good looking but I don't
know if he's accomplished anything is
that sort of a facade is his good body
well we don't know we're going to have
to figure that out you know it's all
about the record once you start
destroying people it's not you know you
have guys looking freaking awesome in
the UFC and killing everybody but then
you have guys who look really great and
who would be favored or who do you think
would win with uh Tommy Fury versus Jake
Paul if they fought today you see that's
a hard one now because that's where God
yeah I Gotta Give the props to uh
he really I start really to like this
guy and the reason I like him is because
the speech that he made after the time
remotely knock out he started talking
about listen guys he grabbed the
microphone and uh you know I never
understand I was a bully but I realized
now because I started boxing and I did
so many it's training is so hard I take
it to the next level you know I realized
I was an [ __ ] I was a bully and you
know and now it's stopped and I'm now I
want to be positive to the people and I
go wow when you see him running and he's
doing everything you know and BJ Flores
is his coach it's a friend of mine uh
and but he's everything that he says he
was going to do he's doing I mean
Anderson Silva and I go if everybody was
and I was thinking too Anderson was
going to win this fight but still he
beat him you know yes he's older but he
beat him you know so you got to give
props to a guy like that he's not
running right you know anyone you think
he would beat Fury no I'm saying it's a
hard one to call but I've never seen
Fury fight to tell you this with so I
just need to see that but the the
willingness and the heart that Jake Paul
has right now you know his breathing
could be better that always but I always
look at the breathing but he will get
even more stamina
um it's a hard one because he hits heart
he starts knocking people out left and
right I mean hanging with freaking
Anderson Silva should say it all
right yeah no matter what the ages you
this guy he's he's you know what he's
doing right now which is very
interesting with Jake Paul he's
baptizing a lot of people not not in the
ring I'm not talking about he baptized
got knocked him out he's converting a
lot of people into liking him and
believing in him which is kind of
interesting you never thought it was
going to happen with him but it has
happened with him so with all the
craziness taking place I believe future
looks bright if you believe future looks
bright get your latest Future looks
bright hat of valuetainment it says
future looks bright here future looks
bright here we got him in white we got
them in Black we got them in red are
black on black sold out these are about
to sell out if you haven't ordered one
yet we had a person in Michigan but one
then he bought three then when those
three people weren't in the office they
had to order 58 of them because people
wanted the future looks bright hat
especially during times like this
because ain't nobody saying future looks
spread toward your future looks bright
hat click over here and to watch the
entire podcast click here take care
everybody
foreign
[Music]